[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM SHAFER: We left for
college in the fall of '77.
The school was well-known
for the business education
that it had at that time.
And it was really emerging as
a leader in thought process
about kind of an independence.
The liberal arts
experience that I
had was very
important to beginning
to discover both
the world around you
and yourself a little bit.
So I think, for me, it was a
real appreciation for areas
that I don't know that I would
have taken myself to had I not
had opportunity to
go to Hillsdale.
I met my wife there.
We were engaged my senior year.
Mary and I both have just
great memories of our time
together at Hillsdale.
It's the people that
you always remember--
your professors that had an
impact on you, your friends.
It was just to me a
magical experience.
I was engaged when I
came out of college,
got married right away, started
in the banking business.
It was 1981.
The economy was a wreck.
I have been basically with
three companies during that time
period.
I had an opportunity to work for
people that I had respect for,
people that gave
me opportunities.
For the last decade or so,
I've been either a president
or a CEO in the
banking business.
The company we're with today
is headquartered in Detroit,
having merged
Chemical Bank and TCF.
The last merger was my
26th merger or acquisition.
The industry's just been
changing at the light of speed.
It's going to continue.
So while I spend a tremendous
amount of time in the banking
business, I spent a
significant lot of time
in organizational development.
I'm incredibly honored to be
receiving the Distinguished
Alumni Award.
I had a great career there.
I've got lifelong
friends from there.
I went to school
with people that I
have so much respect for
that have done things
that I think
completely eclipse what
I've done during my career.
But I'm truly proud of my
association with Hillsdale,
honored to receive this
award, and will cherish it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]